welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 16.
i interviewed mark bell this week mark
bell
is an american professional power lifter
holds a number of patents and trademarks
is the owner of super training gym and a
former professional wrestler
he's successfully squatted 1080 pounds
and bench pressed 854 pounds in lifting
gear
as well as bench pressed 578 pounds
unequipped
now none of that means very much to me
to be honest other than the fact that it
sounds really really heavy
i'm not much into powerlifting shocking
i know
i invited mark on the podcast because he
reached out over a year ago and has been
one of the people who has kept in touch
asking how i am how my dad is and
offering support consistently
even though we haven't met in person
before he's really one of the sweetest
people i know and is passionate about
helping people get fit and improve their
lives
he has over 450 000 followers on youtube
and the same on instagram
he talks about the carnivore diet and
was one of the people who convinced joe
rogan to give it a shot last january
2020
we delve into his background his kratom
product
mind bullet steroids where he got his
nickname smelly
and how to get broken people fit make
sure you subscribe
if you're interested in hearing more i
hope you enjoy the episode
[Music]
welcome to my podcast mark thank you for
joining me
appreciate it i'm super excited for
today
yeah it's good to see you in video not
just on
on the internet over text correct yeah
same business okay thank you very much
uh i wanted to get started with just you
giving a
brief background of who you are and what
it is that you do and
i'll delve into that great
yeah i'm mark bell i uh live in uh
davis california i have a gym called
super training gym in west sacramento
it's 8 000 square feet of uh just
non-stop
powerlifting type stuff that we have
here at super training
and um i've i've been a long time power
lifter
and my way to kind of pay back to the
power of thing community is to offer
this free gym
so whenever some of this coveted stuff
uh blows over anybody that hears this
can come in
on a saturday or sunday any time between
nine and one pm
um and just come in and train with us
and i might be here
um my power to think career started when
i was about 12 years old
i uh started moving around some weights
and my
my brothers were already into power
lifting power lifting is
uh consists of bench press squat and
dead lift
where you go out and you perform a one
rep max in front of three judges
you have three attempts at each lift um
i ended up just being good at it you
know i ended up being really good at it
um
pretty much right away i was a bigger
kid and so i
what i compare it to is like much like
somebody playing the piano
when they're six years old in comparison
to someone else they're just
exponentially a little bit better for
whatever reason i was
exponentially a little bit better than
than a lot of
kids my age especially my friends and
then
i just power things always been in the
background i've always
i've always been doing it i always
enjoyed it it's something i did with a
lot of consistency
for for many many years and
it powerlifting is a thankless sport so
there's not a lot of um especially when
i was doing it when i was younger but
you just it was hard to get recognition
for it and so like i
i wanted to be a professional football
player i wanted to do something
different i
also wanted to become a professional
wrestler at some point
and uh those things never really worked
out for me but lifting was always there
lifting was always the constant
and i was like you know what just stop
resisting it this is what you're good at
this is kind of your calling and so
you need to really just lean into that a
little bit further and then i
uh in my power lifting career i did a
thousand eighty squat an 854 pound bench
a 766 pound deadlift
and those numbers are significant just
because that's what we get judged on
you know uh your dad's a doctor you know
without the
without the you know phd without those
those things
behind the name uh or in front of the
name sometimes you know
it uh it gives people that little extra
bit of credibility in what we do
we specifically get judged by how much
weight we lift
much like a bodybuilder they go on stage
they specifically get judged on how
their body looks and they're
critiqued on that so that's some of my
story
um nowadays i like to lift people more
than i like to lift weights
uh not literally but uh kind of
figuratively lift people up
give people hope i know a lot of people
suffer from anxiety and depression
and i'd love to be able to assist people
and
being able to feel better about
themselves in whatever way i can whether
it's through nutrition or through
working out
um that's what i like to do nowadays
okay you have a a massive instagram
following
uh and i know i know that you're a
proponent of
low carb diets and carnivore diets um
that's part of how i found out about you
so i want to delve into that a bit a
little bit i asked my instagram
folks if they had specific questions for
you so i have something
to do there um and one of the main
things people wanted to talk about
was your experience with nutrition
particularly there are a lot of people
who find it hard to believe that you can
be low carb or carnivore even and have
the kind of strength
you have so what's your journey there
look like what do you do now and
does it work yeah absolutely i actually
joke
very often in the middle of workouts um
especially like when i'm feeling really
good and things are going good in the
gym i'll
i'll be like hey like i'm doing this
without any carbs
like almost as if i'm doing a circus
trick like hey
mom i'm doing this with no net or riding
my bike without my hands or whatever you
know
um the human body is
is uh really complex and it's really
amazing at
what it can do and i think the things
that we used to think
uh were true of it um i think we've
found out that they're
not necessarily true all the time for
everybody in every circumstance and so
for me
um you know having a higher protein diet
um has really been probably the
i've had a higher protein diet since i
was young since i learned about lifting
and since i learned about
um gaining muscle mass and the
importance of protein
i started to up my protein so i've been
on what i would refer to as a meat based
diet for a very
very long time more recently got into
doing some carnivore and some keto style
dieting and
those kinds of things but i'm also not
i try to get too crazy about it for me
personally
i don't i don't i'm very blessed to not
have any digestive
issues i can kind of eat anything
i i've said before i could eat like you
know something from a garbage can or a
sewer or something and probably be
totally fine i don't know why but i got
a
kind of cast iron gut when it comes to
that kind of thing so
um i don't avoid carbs because
that carbs are going to cause me any
harm i don't avoid vegetables because
the vegetables are going to cause me any
harm i just
for me i don't um i don't particularly
like vegetables that much so i mainly
stick with meat
and carbohydrates i want to make it very
clear
for me personally carbohydrates don't
make me fat
but they do encourage me
to eat more food and i will tend to
overeat on kind of these
you know ted neiman refers to it as
their they're like
they're low they're low satiety
high energy foods so meaning it has a
ton of calories
but it doesn't really have a lot of
value for your body because it doesn't
have a lot of protein in it like a
muffin
or a donut or pizza you know these kinds
of things
those are all great but man those those
things
for me uh it's really easy for me to
overeat
uh those types of foods so i really
stick to
trying to eat kind of a higher protein
diet occasionally some rice might find
its way into my diet occasionally some
potatoes might find their way into my
diet i might eat some fruit
here or there but for the most part it's
pretty darn low carb
if i was to say like in the course of a
week
i might have you know 100 or 200 grams
of carbs just
during the week you know so i might have
i don't know
30 or 50 you know in a given day and
and stuff like that so the carbohydrates
are still really low and again it's it's
not
too i want to make sure that i
paint the picture correctly it's i don't
feel that carbs make me
fat i actually don't feel like
carbohydrates really make anyone fat
i do think that pulling them out of your
diet though i think is a
um for a lot of people's a good idea
because it really helps with
like restriction discipline but you know
to to make it make the most amount of
sense
and to make it the easiest is it just
will probably prevent you from
overeating
and that way you can stay on course and
on track with
leaning more towards the body that you
want and in addition to that
if you can lose weight if you lose body
fat for most people again there's some
people that are
thin as it is and they probably don't
need this but um
for a lot of people if you lose you know
even just
10 of your body weight if you weigh you
know 200 pounds and you lost
20 pounds that's going to give you a lot
of
great results in terms of your overall
health
so a lot of times when people just lose
weight
they feel a lot better a lot of times
when they just lose some weight
they will will be a little healthier so
how you lose the weight it's kind of up
to you there's a lot of different ways
of dieting
yeah did you notice any loss of strength
or
why do you add the rice in is it just
because you like rice or does it help
with
lifting or or what so uh what will
happen is
is when you're on a low carbohydrate
diet for a long time and
i always again i just i'll keep
referring to myself and my own
experiences because i don't know
uh how these things have worked out on
other people but when i've gotten my
i do a lot of blood work and i i try to
make sure that i'm heading
in the right direction with everything
my blood resting blood glucose fasted
blood glucose is kind of high and
that is very normal amongst people that
do low carbohydrate
diets um there's a million reasons for
why that might might be
i'm not going to go into that part but
in short
to kind of keep my blood sugar at a
better level and then also get the
reward
of actually eating carbohydrates that
turn into glucose in your body
i was just like you know i think it just
makes more sense to eat a little bit of
carbohydrate here and there
and so that's what i did and my resting
glucose my fasted glucose rather is um
is now a little bit lower and i don't
think that that's like a great marker of
health necessarily but
um i was like it's high and i don't eat
carbs
so my body's probably you know taking
the protein
turning into glucose something of that
nature
i don't like to get into the science of
it a ton because
that's not my strength and i don't i
don't
propose to be anything other than what
than than what i am but
anyway i found it useful for me just to
go to the
straight to the source of carbohydrates
and utilize them and then maybe
in some way maybe that's preventing uh
my protein from
you know kind of turning into a sugar in
my body type thing
yeah that's really interesting i know um
i know
dr sean baker put up his blood work and
then got a lot of hell for putting up
his blood work even though
he was just being honest about putting
up his blood work and his
fasted uh blood glucose level was high
for someone who doesn't
um eat any sugar and i was wondering if
it had anything to do with
i like one the amount he eats because
he'll eat like
four or five pounds of meat in a day or
two
how much actual exercise he does and i
don't know
like i'm with you i'm going to just
avoid the background science on that but
i thought maybe that had something to do
with
his body yeah turning the protein into
sugar i do know there's a relationship
between like cortisol
and your glucose and stuff but like i
don't want to misspeak and say a bunch
of stuff that i don't know what
know a ton about but i i think dr
baker's fine
you know what i mean like dr baker he he
looks amazing
he's in his 50s he is
extremely strong he is world class and
in rowing i mean he
the guy is an animal so um
for people to you know get stirred up
about that is it's kind of interesting
because i've i've seen him work out i've
worked out with him before and he's an
absolute
beast but i think something that people
can keep in mind if they do want to
avoid carbohydrates
or maybe they do need to avoid
carbohydrates because maybe
like yourself maybe they've run into
autoimmune disorders and maybe they've
had
a lot of pain and a lot of suffering
from eating
they just have kind of a long list of
foods that they can't eat
and that that sucks that that's you know
the case for some people but
what's really cool is you can just up
your protein
and you can have your glucose be a
little higher and you can perform like a
beast
still in the gym what i noticed for
myself is
is two probably major things one is
you know being severely restricted of
calories will make you feel like crap
losing weight can help make you feel
good but there's like
you know it's a it's a balance right
there right
whatever you're doing with your diet
what i would suggest is that there
shouldn't be like too much suffering
going on it shouldn't be
it shouldn't be that hard um
the reason it shouldn't be that hard is
because you should be prepared for
whatever level of diet that you're going
to do
and you should be able to handle it um
in even the amount of exercise too
everything should be
i love having a conversation with
somebody and they're like mark i tried
what you said
and they're like i lost you know 15
pounds
in you know two months or whatever and
normally a lot of times what they'll say
is and
they'll follow it up by saying and it
wasn't that hard like if i'm being
honest it really wasn't now
i just had to stop being a jerk with my
food and i had to stop you know stuffing
my face with
with food and i had to break a couple
habits and um
i really think that that is the key and
um
you know i really love trying to add to
people's
day and add to people's life rather than
try to subtract out so much
and have people kind of feeling crappy
and
um under eating there's a lot of people
that under eat
you know so there's a good percentage of
the people that go to the gym
that under eat and there's a good
percentage of the people that go to the
gym that
that ovary and self-sabotage their diet
with too much food
and there's a lot of people at the gym
that are gonna really struggle to make
progress or
or gain muscle mass because they just
simply
aren't giving themselves themselves the
nutrition that they need
in terms of protein you can jack your
protein through the roof
i mean you really can you can eat you
can eat protein
um until your heart is content you can
you can eat a you know gram per pound of
body weight
you can eat 1.5 grams per pound of body
weight you can go all the way up to two
i've seen people even do a little bit
more than that it's it's a preposterous
amount of food to try to eat so that's
the real uh
challenge of it but for me personally at
the moment i'm
on a diet where i try to eat about 400
grams of protein
per day and that's given me tremendous
fuel in the gym
um i i feel really good
yeah everything's kind of running on all
cylinders but again that that's
something that i worked into
you know so i don't want someone
listening to this being like oh i need
400 grams of protein no you probably
don't just
you know maybe uh add 50 grams of
protein to your diet and
see how that feels at first yeah
um so do you train anyone do you work
with people with injuries
i know your brother has he he's had his
joint one of his joints replaced right
yeah he had both yeah both his hips yep
oh man
and was that that was that just
arthritis
not just arthritis but you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
isn't it funny yeah arthritis can like
hurt like crazy
or tendonitis or some of these things
that we just hear in passing
like oh someone has elbow tendonitis
like that's not a big deal
but it's a big deal yeah it can hurt
really bad but yeah he had arthritis
um throughout his body but he also just
was born just a little different like
his his knees and his hips
uh were a little out of alignment you
know since the time he was born so he
had to have knee surgeries when he was
young
and then he had to have uh his hips
replaced uh
later on but um i do i have helped a lot
of people
um you know get get through injuries
with my brother in particular i think
for him it has to be a comprehensive
approach he has to make sure that he's
getting enough sleep
um he has to make sure he stays hydrated
all the time he has to make sure his
nutrition's on point
and you know that what a like what a
great metaphor for life some of us have
to
do so much just to have our little heads
bobbed above the water a little bit so
we don't drown
you know and that's just the way things
are some people have to work
insanely hard to provide for their
family and
they have to spend you know 60 hours a
week at work
other people figure it out a little
differently with nutrition we see the
same thing there's that guy or that girl
that's always eating a pizza but they're
in great shape and you're like i just
don't get it
[Music]
but yeah with my brother he's got to
really uh stay on target and on point
otherwise he'll end up
being in chronic pain yeah yeah
i feel that so what do you tell like how
do you
get strong if you're weak like because
you said you don't want to do anything
that hurts you
if you're somebody it's very difficult
going on social media and seeing these
people who are already in shape showing
you how to do
glute bridges and you're like well yeah
but what do you do if you're
like broken yeah i feel like there are a
lot of people who watch my podcast or
are attracted to my message because
they're broken i'm allowed to call them
broken because i'm kind of broken
so how do you start at a broken stage
and
get strong are there certain exercises
you focus on or
i'm talking to a bunch of people that
are broken down right now damn
like the world is broken down right now
to be fair
you know so um
lifting heavy weights you know it does
come at a cost i think i think everybody
knows that
you know i think a lot of people that
have a uh a history of back injuries
they look at a deadlift and they're like
no no way am i going to do that right
but i think the opposite is actually the
case i think that you need to kind of
lean into some of the stuff that you may
think
would be dangerous for you because i
think it will strengthen you i think
a lot of times in life not always but a
lot of times in life when we have these
things that we
once you say you can't do something
that's probably a good thing to like
investigate
it's probably good to like look into
that like i'm sure you probably said
before you probably were like i can't do
a loca i can't do a no carb diet i can't
only eat meat like that sounds crazy
that sounds ridiculous yeah definitely
and then you're like well i shouldn't
that sounds actually like i'm
speaking uh irrationally since i've
never tried it
so i think i should maybe give it a shot
so i think
the first thing is to um is to know that
it takes a long time to get to to gain
strength it takes a long time to get to
get
strong but i've also i've never met
somebody that doesn't possess the
ability to get stronger
everyone possesses the ability to be a
little bit better than they were
yesterday
and the way that you're going to do that
is um
you want to make sure that you have you
first of all you want to learn how to do
the exercise
that's going to be that's going to be
critical that's probably the hardest
part is figuring out like
who am i going to learn from um i have
like literally thousands of videos
on bench squat deadlifts and so you can
check out any of my stuff on youtube um
there's tons of tons of great resources
all over the internet so um and if you
can get someone in person if you can
hire a personal trainer say hey
you know i'd love you to show i'd love
to learn how to do some movements that
are going to help
you know get me a little stronger
obviously you might run into some people
that aren't great or don't match up well
with you but don't quit you know try to
find someone that's going to work well
but from there once you have the
technique down what you want to really
try to do is
you don't want to take on this like
david goggins mindset
especially out of the gate david goggins
is amazing he's
you know he's um he's inspirational to
to to millions and millions of people
um but you don't want to ignore the
feedback that you get from your body so
i would say like if anything hurts on
like a level of
three out of ten if it hurts
above a three you know if you're
starting to get like a four or five in
your knee or elbow or something like
that or you're back
you need to discontinue the exercise for
the day and you need to just know like i
can come back tomorrow
and i can get this or i can work with
this weight for a few weeks
and then i can continue but you want to
work
probably in a rep range that is anywhere
between 8 to 12 reps
the reason why i suggest 8 to 12
repetitions is because
if we go to the lower end you're going
to use
you're going to use weights that you
might be unfamiliar with
you're going to use weights that are a
little heavier if you're just doing one
rep or two reps three reps and so on
you're just gonna be overloading your
body a little bit too much for
what you might be used to and so stick
to the eight to twelve rep range and
really work on
nailing down the form don't try to do
anything fancy just be
consistent um have a decent tempo a
tempo just is in reference to
how long it takes you to do the movement
so you might go
three seconds on the way down a squat or
a bench press and then three seconds on
the way up
just uh really not not so much about the
count
and how and the time necessarily but
just demonstrate
um really good control and maybe you
know one week you're using 20 pound
dumbbells and maybe
a couple weeks down the road you're
using 25s and and so on but
just um you're gonna have to take the
the long road which is the road that
nobody
uh really wants to take um
and also there's a lot you can get from
bodyweight exercises too
and if bodyweight exercises hurt then
um you're you're not you're just not in
great condition
you know those areas of your body that
hurt like if you you struggle to get
down and do a push-up
but your body kind of hurts even to get
into position or you notice your elbow
hurts really bad or to do a squat or a
lunge your knee is in tons of pain
you're you're you absolutely have to
figure out a way to start doing those
things because once you're able to do
those things
everything else your quality of life
going up and down the stairs getting in
and out of your car
uh playing with your children all that
stuff will
increase a ton i mean imagine if imagine
if there was just no block between you
and and doing whatever it is you want
chasing your niece or nephew
or getting on the ground with them and
playing
you would be more likely to do it if you
just i mean how we
feel is like is the most important thing
and that's one reason why you want to
lean into strength because
like being strong and feeling strong uh
makes you feel awesome about yourself
it's a great accomplishment so i really
strongly suggest anybody listening to
this you know
you know start to start to figure out a
way to to get after it in whatever way
you can
yeah i have to remember that a lot
because i have pain i have pretty much
chronic pain in my ankle and it's better
than it was since i had a revision
surgery
but if i don't even do something like
walk if i'm super stressed and i don't
do exercise for a while the pain does
get worse because my leg gets weaker
and then when i start again it hurts and
it's hard to remember that that
pain isn't necessarily something to
dissuade you from continuing like you
kind of just have to
push through it a little bit because the
pain lessens if you get stronger
it is definitely something what about
something like um
running probably kills it huh
i just yeah like i started i ran for the
first time this year on this
fancy treadmill type thing like limp
ran but running not quite yet
my like the left my left leg is so
atrophied
from like 12 years of not being able to
move my ankle it's insane
walking like i people kind of downplay i
think
walking especially online because it's
not as
sexy of an exercise but i've been like
walking and that's helped strengthen me
a lot i had to start like just i talked
to one
guy who um his name's cole who does the
snake diet
coleridge he deals with i love cole
robinson
but he deals with really overweight
people and he tells them to stand
just start there which is like something
to think about so i started like pretty
slow with just
walking there's a lot of stuff you can
do even while you walk i mean you can
walk with your feet
pointed you know more inward you can
work walk with your feet pointed more
outward
just for a little while just you know
especially if you have like knee or
ankle
issues you could just it's probably
going to be really uncomfortable
you'll be like wow like that sucks even
just to do it for just a couple steps or
whatever but
um it is strengthening and stretching
you obviously don't want it again you
don't want to do anything that's gonna
like really
hurt um but like what i'll do a lot of
times on my walks is i'll stop and if i
see like a bench
which is pretty common you just if
you're walking in like a downtown area
you might see a bench like
hit up some squats on there and you know
move a little bit or just even sit down
just for a minute
but you know when you go to get back up
and do you know go back to your walk you
just maybe do a couple squats
things like that you know just try to
figure out a way to keep moving and for
you
it actually might be really beneficial
would be to
do some very very small jumping where
you just
you you ju you just come off the ground
just to just a pinch you know
and uh land every time
you're not trying to jump onto anything
or off of anything but just
just jump a little bit in the air like
almost even like a jump rope or
something
would be well that would probably take
you a little while to get used to that
but
your your bone density will increase a
ton just from jumping just from the
impact so running
running can be great because you can
increase bone density through running
you can increase bone density through um
through lifting weights you know
so through some lifting uh you could
increase some bone density but
also just through just a small amount of
jumping i mean even if you
were like i'm going to try to do i don't
know 20 of them a day
and just i'm talking about like little
tiny hops just your
body just comes off the ground a little
bit and make sure you kind of cushion
the blow each time
you know make sure you're like kind of
landing safely you can even do it on a
surface that is
a little bit uh squishy like a yoga mat
or something like that you know or you
can even do it on
a carpet or a pillow or something and
you can do it like barefoot just to help
strengthen your ankle a little bit
yeah i like that i'm going to take a
video of it and
a year or once i'm once i'm better at it
that's good
so for the biggest strongest ankles
anyone's ever seen
eventually it is it's going to be that's
my goal
to have strong legs it'll happen at some
point i'm positive about it
okay let's switch directions um you
talked to me a number of months ago
about kratom
is that how you say it uh you could say
it whatever
you want yeah kratom yep i have some
sitting right here i have a product
called mine
fancy fancy with kratom
so i tried your mind bullet and the
first time i called
i tried kratom it just is crate i'm
right
um the first time i tried it i i bought
what i thought was
solid kratom in this really really
sketchy florida
store which obviously if you say it that
way sounds like a bad idea and i think
it was a bad idea because i tried it and
i
tried a small dose so i think i tried
two grams which i think is a small dose
and it felt like caffeine at the
beginning and then
i had the most horrible response and it
was just like
nausea and sweating and like serious
sweating and i was like whoa
i don't know if this was just kratom
anyway i tried mind bullet and that
didn't happen so i think it was just the
sketchy
florida convenience store but what's
your experience with kratom bin and
why do you use it why do you sell it
yeah i like it a lot i
my brother um turned me on to it a
couple years ago
again he's had a lot of pain and he kept
trying to tell me
he's like i think you'd like it because
i know you're you're always like sore
and stuff and
you know from working out and i was like
well
you know i i i just kind of take that as
like part of the game you know so
uh i just you know uh tough guy it out
you know i
i don't i don't really think about it
much i'm like okay well
it's just part of like lifting weights
you know um
but then he told me it puts you in a
really good mood and i was like
okay well i've noticed that sometimes
when i'm coming on my way to the gym
and my favorite song comes on i've
noticed a huge response
in how i work out for the day and how i
interact with everybody else in the gym
and
i'm just happier and i lift really
really well when i'm just
happy and excited about life and when
i'm in a good mood and uh
so i was like all right well i'll try it
before a workout one day and kind of see
what happened
see what happens and it just felt great
it felt really good to me and then i was
you know i would uh take it here and
there on some walks i'd take it here and
there on some
when i do some podcasting and different
things like that
one thing that i try to do with
everything i have a coffee in front of
me as well
one thing i try i try my best to do and
i'm not great at it but i do try to make
sure that i'm not becoming
dependent on anything or or reliant on
anything too much i want to make sure
that it's
i want to make sure it's a decision you
know i don't i
don't want to find myself like oh man
where's my kratom
or oh no i can't function i haven't had
my coffee i'm going to be grumpy
you know you we hear people say stuff
like that so
just i think taking it responsibly i
think it's a wonderful supplement
and it's been valuable to me it adds to
my life
i feel that sometimes it even helps with
creativity
it somehow gives you like a little dose
of empathy too you'll find yourself
texting one of your buddies and being
like i love you man i appreciate you so
much you're the best
so i don't know i don't know why it does
that but uh
for me personally i like to i like it a
lot and a lot of the people here at
super training uh
enjoy it and a lot of people around the
world uh really like it a lot
i would also say that sometimes um
it's not for everybody i've had people
take it and they're like man i don't
feel anything from that i've
had other people tell me they felt sick
so i just think
much like anything else it's just
something you you try if you feel that
you
uh might get a good response from it and
uh
if you don't think it's something that
you should try then don't worry about it
and do you how much do you use if you're
using for a pre-workout
i usually use about three to four
capsules which is
uh each one is like 750 milligrams so
um i would probably be in like that two
gram range that you
mentioned earlier um i think i also sent
you some mind bullet potion as well
which is
yeah that that is that i tried yeah that
stuff is uh that stuff is very strong
that's kind of the equivalent of like
eight pills or something like that but
that will
uh it will send you to the clouds and
back you know it just
and people are like hey well isn't that
like getting high and i'm like yeah
pretty much i mean
it is you get you get it you get a
little high you get a little
boost um but i think you get that from
your coffee too i just think that we
don't
we don't recognize that anymore you know
we can't remember our first
uh cup of coffee or our first you know
cup of tea but
i think a lot of these things do some
similar stuff
and people are really reaching out for
nootropics and stuff
and trying to you know have their brain
function a little bit better and
it doesn't really work that way but i
think what it does do is it might
you know kind of lower some inhibitions
that you may have about yourself it
might lower a little bit of self-doubt
that you may have about yourself
that's been my experience personally and
then it allows
i think once you kind of pull that stuff
back
it allows you to think a little bit
better because you don't doubt your
thoughts as much
you're not like well that's that's dumb
well you know what would so-and-so think
if you said that or what would so-and-so
think if you told them this idea they
would think it's dumb
it seems to pull some of that back from
me so that's what i really enjoy about
it a lot especially because
here at super training i make products
and i have
several inventions so it helps with the
creativity side of things
yeah i found it relaxing like kind of
stimulating but
calming and relaxing yeah uh
okay inventions what kind of inventions
do you have i know you have the
slingshot
yeah so i i created the slingshot 10
years ago
it's a supportive upper body device for
bench press push-ups dips
and we've been selling it online for
for several years now you can get it you
know on my website
markbellslingshot.com or you can get it
on amazon or roguefitness
we've been selling worldwide and things
have been going really good with that
behind that i have a bunch of other
stuff that i created or invented
um that has some things have kind of
uh slipped out of my hands because you
can only patent so many different things
um i wasn't able to patent the hip
circle the hip circle is a
uh is the booty bands that you see all
the girls using that you know you put
around your
knees and you walk forward and backwards
and squat with it and stuff that's my
creation that thing did not exist
uh before i put it out there into the
into the world so
uh in addition to that i created a bunch
of other products around
around the slingshot itself because i
i knew that you know it was a good idea
to have this product
but there's a big difference between
having a product and having a
business and so in order to turn
everything into a to turn it more into a
business i needed to
uh make other things that support you
during your workout so i make
elbow sleeves and knee sleeves and wrist
wraps and
anything that you can think of uh to
have your workout be less painful
than uh than we we make it because
i think the barrier of entry and it's
part of the reason why my gym is free
the barrier of entry into fitness
into strength training um into really
any of it is
it's intimidating and the first time you
do it
you know you you you don't get a reward
you get
pain like it hurts it doesn't it does
you know a friend can be like you got to
come with me you got to work out with me
you got to try this and then you try it
and you're like man that sucked
made you throw up and made you super
sore or you're like that that was
you're like what are you talking about
what are you a masochist like that was
awful so we try to make it a little a
little easier a little bit more
comfortable for
uh people to get into exercising and
lifting weights
yeah i had a number of friends try hot
yoga
and i actually haven't tried hot yoga so
i can't even comment on this
really but a number of them went in
they're like yeah this is great i've got
my outfit on
and they just did an hour of hot yoga
threw up came outside and it was just
like yeah i paid for that
it wasn't great yeah it depends on what
kind of yoga you
get yourself into you know i so i've
done some yoga and
um i had to explain to them i'm like
like what i'm like what is like a
calming
style of yoga like what's something
where you don't really have to move
around a lot because
i've gone into other yoga workouts and
they were doing some like power vinyata
yoga or something i've never heard i
don't know any of these terms
and so i went in there and i'm like damn
i'm like these
these chicks are like actually like
getting it like they're
they're they're like full-on working out
and then
i'm like well that girl's kicking my ass
and i'm we're doing basically they're
doing like burpees i'm like what the
hell is going on in here
and you know we were doing some like
stretching and stuff too but i got my
ass kicked in that class and then so
from that point on i was like i think
i'm gonna ask ahead of time of like what
i'm getting myself into before i before
i go in there
yeah i had the same experience with i
don't want cycling
which i just went to one of those
cycling classes where you can't sit on
the bike you're just always up and
yeah like it almost killed me i don't
think i'd be able to do one of those
classes
i get crushed yeah yeah
uh okay so how did you get
you have like i said you have this large
online following
you've been on joe rogan a number of
times um
when did you start selling products and
how did you get into the whole
online what i mean was it initially
online sales or was this
in store like how did this start
10 years ago you said that was quite a
while to get into kind of an
e-commerce type thing right yeah so um
i was probably kind of a early adopter
of some of that so that helps a lot you
know having a little bit of a lineage
uh behind it but um
so before youtube there was something
called put file
and i was putting up uh videos of me
lifting and other lifters in my gym
super training um we've had
many many lifters squat over 900 pounds
many lifters squat over a thousand
pounds and
bench press over 800 pounds and so years
ago
probably more like 12 or 13 years ago i
was like you know what like
people are gonna want to see this like
this is like i just knew that it was
weird and different you know i'm like
i'm like what we do is is strange you
know we
we sit here for hours on end like and
all we care about is these weights
and i'm like and no one outside this gym
cares at all
about you know i think uh guys initially
think that like if i lift a bunch of
weight
chicks are gonna dig me but really the
only people that uh
really the only uh admiration you might
get is from other guys
and so and so it's kind of a weird thing
and i'm like what is this
all about why do we love this so much
and i was just
uh obsessed with trying to get get that
out to the world and show them like hey
look this is pretty neat like look at
how
not look at how strong these people are
but
look at how these look at how yeah look
at how these people are working on
something
and progressing you know because we
would have a girl come in
and squat 300 pounds and then you know
months later they were squatting 400
pounds
it was more like the progression it
wasn't so much about the actual weight
it just happened to be that a lot of the
people that were
in our facility were very very very
strong
so that's how i kind of got a foothold
in
in being like i guess known on the
internet and then there was a website
years ago called elitefts.com elite
fitness systems
uh with a guy by the name of dave tate
and i worked
under him so they had they had training
logs on there
and they had training logs of some of
the best uh
power lifters in the world some of the
best strength coaches in the world
and at that time i actually wasn't even
very strong in comparison to
uh how strong some of these people were
that were on this forum
this is you know again 12 15 years ago
and
uh i got i i got the the name jackass on
there because
uh dave tate who runs the website was
like hey this would be great if you were
on here
and no one knew who you were but you
just messed with everybody
so i would just mess with all the other
people that were on that
on that site and i would mess with the
fans that would write into um
you know it was it was like a forum type
thing and i would just kind of like
mess around and like raise hell on there
and screw around and
i just that's kind of how i got a little
bit of uh
a little bit of fame but at the time i
was the only person
that was posting video so i you know i
was one of the first people to
put some of these videos up on a website
that was uh
pretty big so it ended up ended up
working out really well but that's how i
got
attention was just through just shooting
a lot of videos and i still think that
people today
uh even though it's a slower climb and
there's uh
there's a lot of competition i think
that like
if you feel like you have a niche thing
that you're good at you should be
filming it you should be like you know
podcast
is is great too because i think that
each person's voice is going to be
relatable to someone different
and so i would encourage you to do that
as well writing a book is a good idea
because i think again people will be
encouraged by that voice and then like
whatever you have inside i think it's
important to get it out
so you should be writing it anyway even
if no one else read it
um but in terms of like you know trying
to get a following
you need to document like what's going
on like what are you what are you doing
and i don't think you need to really
work really hard at like hey what's
going to define me what's going to make
me different than this other girl this
other guy
i think that's where you get yourself
into some weird traps just do you and
like what
what are you into you into you like
fashion and you're into clothes
cool just talk about it just talk about
it but talk about it every day
you know try to film it try to document
it in some fact in some way
yeah those are good tips people also
really like to see other people
succeeding
it doesn't even matter where you're
starting from right even if you're
starting from way down people like to
see
you winning and it's just like a little
win yeah so like we we intentionally do
a lot of stuff
um where you know i'll say oh don't
don't use that guy for that video
because like he's
he's like he's too good you're like
don't you know
don't use our guy that's uh you know 220
pounds and shredded let's
let's use the guy that's like 160 and
starting and
he wants to be 180 he wants to have more
muscle or let's use the girl that
is on a journey of dropping some body
weight you know
rather than rather than always
showcasing like
uh the best right because people just
they have a harder time
identifying what they're like i don't
they're like i don't know how to do that
i don't know
i don't know what it's like to be the
rock you know you try to
like okay maybe you start here and you
start adding stuff to your
resume you start adding stuff to what
you're able to handle every day and then
maybe eventually
maybe you're able to start to become
something that other people view as a
success
yeah i agree uh so i did a bit of
background research
which i generally do for my speakers but
specifically for you
i did some plus i got a whole bunch of
questions on instagram
and people brought up steroid use
i wanted to get into that i want to know
about it
because i read some articles and some of
them where you had interviews and you
were talking about its use and the
benefits and drawbacks and
i'm interested i don't know anything
about that michaela peterson
i have the utmost respect for your dad
and out of respect for him i have to
tell you that steroids are bad
and that you shouldn't ah no no no i
need more information than that there's
got to be i mean everyone
like from what i read and like i said i
don't really know anything about it but
like
everybody who lifts incredibly heavy
weights kind of uses them
right so yeah steroids are steroids are
very very popular
i i think one of the first books ever
written
one of the first popular books ever
written on steroids was called the
underground
steroid handbook and the underground
steroid handbook i don't think they had
any idea
how many copies of that they were going
to sell
uh but from what i've heard they sold
like 250
000 of them um in in a fairly short
in a fairly short period of time because
because like
again at the time nobody really thought
i guess no one really knew who was doing
what and who wasn't
um but it i believe that book was
written by a guy named dan duchene
and the the reason why he wrote the book
was because
there was just so many dangerous
practices going on and so much
misinformation
that he was like you know i'm just going
to write a book about it because
i can't believe the way people are
obtaining this information and i can't
believe what's getting passed around
as being you know viable information and
even today it's a little weird like
if you wanted to start to take steroids
you're like i don't even know and
and also we get uh put in youtube
jail and instagram jail uh all the time
for
even mentioning steroids a lot of times
um
so the basics of it are if you look at
like the supplement industry
there's a lot of different amino acids a
lot of different supplements you can
take
to help you gain muscle mass but for the
most part those things
don't really they may work over like a
really long period of time and they may
work
very very slowly but there's as much
information to show that they don't work
and there's as much information that
might show that they do any information
that shows that they do work
is probably uh it probably has an agenda
to show why it works because they're
probably trying to sell you on something
but steroids without question they
will add muscle mass to your body um
how they do so and and so forth i don't
i don't even know all the mechanisms
behind all that but i do think it has to
do with protein synthesis
basically just allowing your body to
kind of turn over the protein that
you're getting
a little faster and allowing you to
potentially recover from your workouts
maybe a little easier
but steroids have been massively
influential in my life and i think that
it's it's really undersold what drugs in
general do
um so joe rogan's not joe rogan
without marijuana um and it's not a
knock on joe rogan it's just
it's just the truth i'm not who i am
without steroids arnold's not arnold
without
arnold's not the governor of california
without steroids
you know in my in my opinion you know
like it that might sound
really weird to say but he's probably
not multiple time mr olympia
he may not be a movie star um
and i'm not saying that arnold would be
nothing without them either he would
still
be you know if he want chose to lift
weights and be
the most jacked person he could be he
would
he would be but would he have the best
physique and the most legendary
physique of all time probably not
because there would be people that
took steroids that got enhanced beyond
that
if you think about any you know great
musicians and
just great people over the years that
have written great
poetry or sang some amazing songs i mean
there's
there's a long lineage of like drug use
and unfortunately drug abuse that goes
along with that
um eminem openly talking about uh
mushrooms percocet all different kinds
of stuff right i'm not i'm not endorsing
any of this but
um drugs and steroids included steroids
are a drug
all drugs and i would i would include
coffee and alcohol in
in this mix as well all drugs take you
from
where you currently are to a place that
you otherwise
probably wouldn't be able to get to
whether you're talking about
psychedelics whether we're talking about
kratom
uh or whether we're talking about
steroids and so for me as a kid i was
always so fascinated by them i was like
you know what i think one day i'm gonna
do those because i love to work out i
love to lift weights i love
i love the feeling of being strong and
it would be really interesting to see
what would happen if i had something
that accelerated that process
uh it's it's not even so much for you as
it is with you
like it accelerates it with you rather
than for you because
it's not going to do anything for you if
you don't do anything so
you need to exercise you need to still
have discipline you know but
i guess the easiest way to
the easiest way to shape the picture for
most people is
most of the people listening to this
right now if they
currently have a decent regimen of
exercise
um and they were they were to uh
utilize some steroids they would just
have a little bit more muscle mass
uh having more muscle muscle uh cost you
calories and like who wouldn't want to
burn some extra calories every day
without having to
your your muscles are um
your muscles are almost like a like a
treadmill if you
if you will it's almost like you did an
extra 15 minutes of cardio the more
muscle mass that you have
something to that equation you know
because the muscles are chewing up
energy uh throughout the day they're
chewing up calories they can help with
your
uh your blood sugar and they can help
with all kinds of different things but
yeah steroids are a really i don't know
how
we got to a point where they're like uh
kind of demonized and
people get you know all worked up over
whether someone's natural or
not natural um i've always just tried to
be upfront and honest about it and
i when i was younger i was on that side
i was on the natural side and i was like
you know what i don't i don't understand
why people do them but as i started to
get a little older and started to read
more about them i got more and more
excited about them and i was like you
know what just makes sense
if i can do something that's going to
make me better then
uh you know i i'm gonna do that and for
me
i don't view it as cheating because i'm
not competing against people that don't
take them
in powerlifting powerlifting is actually
really weird we don't have
we you can go into a drug a drug tested
federation if you wanted to
um but see like that's where i would
have a problem with it if i was
if i was trying to go into a drug tested
federation and i was saying
hey i'm the same as everybody else and i
was kicking everybody's ass while i'm on
stuff
uh i don't agree with that i think
morally that's that's not a
good route to go but for me um
i and maybe i'm missing something but i
don't think i'm hurting anybody else
it makes me feel good makes me feel
great makes me feel strong
um and yeah just uh
allows me to do okay what i like to do
okay
cool i have i've got a couple of
questions um one
well it's it's funny i've i read a lot
on the internet about the weirdest range
of topics
and steroid use
see it seems like steroid use in eastern
europe is viewed differently than it is
in north america
and part of the medical protocols for
just people with
injury here uh can involve steroid use i
guess because it helps you
grow muscle mass so i thought that was
kind of interesting but do you
have you found downsides because
all i've really heard about in regards
to steroid use are
well it's terrible for your mood like it
can cause
all these health issues so have you
experienced any of that
i would say there's definitely some like
evidence that uh
it'll probably
probably make you more of whatever you
are you know so if you're if you're
not not in every sense of the word but
if you're aggressive um
it might make you more aggressive if
you're an angry person
uh it might it might heighten that a
little bit but i would also say that has
to do with the fluctuation of hormones
so
uh if you get on them and you
take responsible dosages you should be
totally fine now
where you'll really run into an issue is
if you ever decide or when you decide to
come off of them
coming off of them is depressing flat
out like i
i'm somebody that i've been very lucky
in my life i haven't
had all the love i needed as a kid and
got all the hugs and admiration and all
that stuff that i ever needed
i always felt like i had everything i
ever needed so
i never felt bad about myself i've
never really been depressed other than
when i came off steroids a couple times
um you you definitely have a little bit
of like a lag period of
maybe a a couple of weeks now if you
were
if you were somebody that has previously
been like literally
very depressed in your life and you know
to a to a clinical
uh degree well that would be a massive
consideration
uh steroids i i would actually go as far
to say
as that steroids would help you a ton if
you were depressed
however coming off of steroids could be
detrimental and we've seen it happen
we've seen it we've seen it be deadly
to some people um it's because
you're okay you increase your
testosterone right when you're taking
especially if you're taking testosterone
you increase your testosterone
well your body's like hey the
testosterone is way up there we need to
do something to combat that so
you might might produce more estrogen
and then when you come off of everything
your testosterone drops the estrogen
kind of stays about the same
and your your uh now you're going to
have
now you're going to be more sorry ladies
you're going to be more emotional
at this time so that can be
uh that's going to be very very
difficult um
there are a lot there is a lot of
precautions
to to anabolic steroids um
there's a lot of negative side effects
um
you could be you could be messing with
your organs your heart being one of them
uh your liver um so it's not it's not
something to like toy around with it's
something that you need to like think
about
for myself i actually i get my blood
work done
usually twice a year to kind of make
sure things are
not heading in a bad direction but one
of the main things that can happen from
steroid
abuse more so than steroid use is
um you can uh you can make your blood
thick so you can increase your your red
blood cell count
to to a point where your blood is
thicker now
if you already have high blood pressure
and your blood is thicker
you're gonna you're really asking for a
lot of trouble
if you're somebody that struggles with
your diet
and you're looking to take steroids to
help you get
leaner and in better shape uh they can
actually leave you pretty unhealthy
if you haven't figured out how to
navigate through
your daily diet like if you haven't
figured out how to
uh nail down your nutrition because
it's almost as if everything kind of
sticks to you a little bit more
so you could become puffy and bloated i
mean we all know like
the hormones in our bodies or like what
about like you know a night of a night
of drinking you know male or female a
night of drinking and kind of eating
whatever you want you wake up the next
day and
you look like the stay puft marshmallow
man right
everything's gotten really uh really
puffy and so
steroids affect your hormones a lot and
they can
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
to be cautious of and
if you male or female if you want to
have children
that's something else to consider you
know for me
i started taking them when i was 25 and
uh i came off i think when i was maybe
like
uh maybe like in my 30s and had my
second child my daughter quinn who's now
12.
um that to me that was just like
luck that i was able to do that i i know
a lot of people and i don't think it's
coincidental
i know a lot of people that have tried
to come off and try to get their wife
pregnant and it just never
it never worked out they had to like
adopt i mean that's a that is a
that is a that's a huge factor i love my
children i love kids period so
um you know that would that would have
sucked if i wasn't able to
and i don't know who knows like maybe
that would have caused a riff in the
marriage or something like i i don't
have any idea
um so it's not something you just it's
it's a drug
um they can be dangerous um
there's there's a lot there's definitely
a lot to consider it's not something
where you're just like oh yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna go on a i wouldn't recommend
that i wouldn't recommend oh yeah i'm
just gonna go on a cycle
because i think it leaves you
i think it leaves you changed a little
bit forever and so
i would be i would be i'd just be very
cautious with your decision i think that
once you do them then you're probably
going to be on them forever
whether you consider that to be
problematic or not then i guess that
would be up to you
yeah well i think these are
conversations are really important to
have
for like any drug use because people put
some drugs into categories that are like
this is safe
just because and this one is not safe
and sometimes those categories are split
completely wrong and you have
really extremely unsafe drugs in the
safe category and then you're not
allowed to talk about some other ones
for some reason and then people are just
uneducated and scared and then
they don't know what they're doing so
good for you for
telling people about it and educating i
think that's important
yeah i think people need to do their
research
yeah yeah read like don't and don't even
don't even trust us
like go online and read as much as you
can about whatever
you're going to be doing with your life
and as intimidating as it might be
you know you're your local uh jax
bodybuilder you know um
you know careful i guess on how you ask
the question because you may offend
somebody but
i i would rather have you gain more
knowledge rather than you know be super
worried about whether you offend
somebody if you're
if you're a young if you're if you're
not uh
not if you're young if you're if you're
somebody that is not up to speed
on how to do it you know that's how a
lot of people find out
is from the local guy that's jacked ask
him a couple questions say hey man like
and
it would be if that person is trying to
like
sell you on something then that is a
massive red flag
most of the people that you go to should
especially if you're a younger person
should be like dude like just keep
training you know
get just you have so much progress to
make right now
you know i said i took them at 25 but
remember i said i started my lifting
journey at 12.
so there's a lot of years of of training
and a lot of years of even
uh training with pretty good knowledge
from the time i was probably more like
18 or so
until i was 25 you know so so put in put
in some time
and work towards your goals without them
you may find out
i have a bunch of friends they're in
great shape they they look great they're
strong
and they're like yeah i just never
decided to take them i didn't i just
i thought maybe i would need them and
they're like i kept training
i kept getting in better shape i kept
getting what i wanted
and i just felt like i never needed them
it's like damn okay well there you go
yeah there you go well where can people
find you online
you can find me um on instagram
mark smelly bell i have a youtube
channel which is also mark smelly bell
smelly is a nickname i got from my two
mean older brothers
because when i was a kid i hated i hated
to take showers
and so the name it stuck with me forever
but you can also find my products
uh at markbellslingshot.com
and if you want to follow along with
workouts and you want to you know see
exactly how i train and how i eat and
all that stuff you're going to see that
stuff all scattered throughout the
internet for free but if you also want
to follow along
to a greater degree you can go over to
markbell.com
and you can check out how i train now
and how i used to train and
nutrition and all that stuff
okay well thank you i would recommend it
i've watched your i've watched your
workout videos they're very helpful
even for people with injuries although i
like the jumping thing
i have a question for you yes okay
are you ready are you sitting down yeah
i'm sitting down
i want to know i'm curious about
when you were a kid did you
at some point make a decision just to
not ask your dad a question because you
were like
i just so this happened to me when i was
a kid with my dad
so i had asked my dad a question and
then i started realizing like
he would explain it and it would go on
forever
i would just imagine that your dad was
that way and i could picture your mom
being like
honey she just doesn't need to know you
know like she's eight
you know she doesn't need to know all
this stuff
you know what no no that didn't
that didn't happen um i don't think
he always described things in incredibly
interesting ways
it wasn't you know too factual or
anything there was a well it was factual
but there was always a story to go along
with it
so i don't think i ever had a um plus i
had
tell the truth like hammered into my
head into
to an unhealthy degree so that i thought
whatever was in my head i needed to talk
about which
isn't that's not how my brother picked
it up and he was probably a much more
successful teenager than me and was like
so no i pretty much just asked
whatever discussed whatever told people
whatever was going on in my head like i
said
probably probably too much and other
than your ankle bothering you
how are you feeling
pretty good pretty good i like i my goal
right now is to get stronger
because i've been this the last year has
been
so overwhelmingly stressful that i lost
some of the gains i had made and i had
just started making gains because i had
like i said i had this ankle
re-replacement surgery which takes like
a full year and a half to fully heal
so it was like nine months past surgery
and i was just starting to do like
walking and
some exercises so i'm trying to like
force myself into starting but
i'm weak like i'm thin
because of my diet but i'm weak to a
degree that is frustrating and i know i
just have to
be consistent um what
kind of exercise do you like is there a
particular type of exercise like do you
you mentioned walking but do you like uh
like riding a bike or is there anything
in particular that you
have done where you're like oh that's
pretty cool i can see myself
doing that often swimming lifting
weights whatever it might be
well i used to do before my ankle i used
to do absolutely everything
uh and then my ankle wrecked a whole
bunch of things for me like i was like i
hate beaches but it was only because it
hurt to walk on a beach i like beaches
again no one hates beaches right
but um rollerblading i really like so
i was really when i was still in north
america it's harder to rollerblade here
because
everything is broken the sidewalks and
serbia are like
you can't rollerblade here but um
rollerblading and walking i'm starting
with
and i used to do dance
like there are a bunch of things i can
get back into i just need to
probably be less stressed would help and
i know exercise also helps with stress
but
that's where i'm stuck yeah i would say
if if you can find a couple of of the
things that you like
and try to pull down the levels of uh
you know the barriers of entry into
those things whether it be dance or
whatever i mean
dancing there's apps you know you can
have an app and you can
probably dance right right where you're
at pretty much it might be more exciting
to go somewhere and
do it with other people or something
like that but um i would say yeah try to
lean into that like because what you're
interested in
is going to be the thing that's going to
be it's not going to seem hard to you to
do it because you like it you enjoy it
and so uh i would try to lean into that
the best that you can
yeah that might be a good idea could do
some sort of zumba with scarlett
i'm sure she'd enjoy that okay that's
good advice
zumba yeah assuming i'm pronouncing that
right i can't believe i called it kratom
anyway okay thank you very much for
coming on that was really fun
yeah thank you i really appreciate it i
want to let you know that i find you
very inspirational i've been following
along with a lot of your stuff
and so uh i know that you get questions
all day long about your famous dad but i
find you to be motivational and
inspirational as well so
i do listen to a lot of his stuff and uh
i
connect with a lot of the stuff that he
says but i've listened to you on joe
rogan i've listened to you interviewed
on other podcasts
i've listened to this podcast and it
looks like you're on your way it looks
like you're doing an amazing job you
have a lot of followers and you have a
lot of views on your youtube channel
like it looks like things are going
really good so
congratulations on all that i know it it
must be
um it's difficult you know especially
with all the different stresses you had
in the past year but
you're kicking ass you're doing some
amazing things so congratulations
thank you very much i think that those
were more compliments than i've had in a
very long time i'm not entirely sure how
to react to that
thank you mark and thanks for coming on
again you're working for him so
thanks again appreciate it catch you
later catch you later
[Music]
you